[Music]
foreign
what will happen if Godzilla and Kong
died firstly let's take a look at the
g-man's path so that we can ascertain
what will happen to the world in his
absence so in Awakening Godzilla is said
to be an ancient life form from the late
Permian period Dominion challenges this
hypothesis suggesting that he as an
individual existed During the eocene
period he had a symbiotic relationship
with Mothra and fought against Ghidorah
defeating him in the past and sealing
him in Antarctica GVK further mentions a
war between Godzilla and Kong's species
in the past meaning that his past wasn't
always calm and his position as the Apex
Titan has been challenged time and time
again the laws of his kind aside from
him was Dagon and that was killed by
Muto Prime but this all shows that there
were multiple Godzillas throughout
Earth's history either existing as a
population or one after another
therefore there has been no time in the
planet's history without him so on Earth
without Godzilla is kind of scary
Monarch classifies Godzilla as a
protector and a guardian of the world
initially seen as a threat Godzilla is
now considered the greatest defender of
the planet emerging to battle any
aggressor that disrupts the balance of
nature he is territorial aiming to
restore balance wherever it is disrupted
his behavior has evolved from previous
incarnations he shows little interest in
humans and focuses on battling Renegade
Titans and ending potential threats by
attacking humans only if they are in the
precipice of Awakening a world-ending
threat or harming other benevolent
Titans be it Awakening Master zero or
creating Mechagodzilla or even
attempting to capture nakika even
stopping Cilla from attacking ships as
well as breaking off a fight between
amholuk and Behemoth as king of the
monsters he keeps both Titans and humans
in check so what will be the
implications and consequences if he were
to die in gxk and what will the world
look like
firstly without a Godzilla on Earth the
Titans will go wild and attack Humanity
as in the case of king of the monsters
well this one was in the behest of
Ghidorah but who is to say that another
Titan among them would not call the
others for a hunt like Monster Zero we
do know that there are less so
benevolent irons and also Destroyer
Titans that will love nothing else but
to act as their instincts tell them too
camazod Rodan and maybe even the mutos
could go on a rampage
secondly we know that Godzilla and Kong
are as of now to do with Apex Titans in
the monster verse gong can't really
travel the world and put a check to
other monsters so without the Big G
there will be no doubt a massive Titan
Civil War a series of battles between
beta monsters for dominance and to
become a new Alpha Titan the most likely
ones to initiate this would be either
amholic or Rodan Rodan for obvious
reasons as he as was seen in kotm did
challenge ghidoro at first and then only
bowed down to Godzilla after Monster
Zero was vanquished knowing his place in
the hierarchy of power
thirdly a surprising consequence that
might arise from Godzilla's death would
be the eventual demise of the muto
species in other words they would go
extinct due to a lack of a viable life
cycle requirement confused no worries
the murals evolved specifically to
counter the Gojira species their EMP
powers are designed to dampen the atomic
powers of Godzilla and most of all a
major part of their life cycle in which
the muto Prime lays living spores to
hatch into a sexual dimorphic phase
requires a radiation-rich body of a
Gojira species Ergo nogojira no spores
hence no Muto
fourthly so if there were no Garden of
Earth there would be a massive war
between Titans lots of them will be
killed in the process and if Scar the
red Kong and shimu the original were to
arise from the hollow Earth without any
challenge there would be Bloodshed on a
Titan scale
for your information in the lore it was
actually confirmed that it was Godzilla
to defeated and imprisoned Scar in The
Hollow Earth following his war against
all Titans it was also confirmed that
scar is a hunter and delights in killing
other super species so along with shimu
all life on Earth will be in Barrel
lastly suppose Godzilla and Khan dies in
their battle against Scar and shimu in
gxk and given that Mothra is still an
egg as well as no other Titan being able
to rise up to the mantle of being a true
Global protector therefore if there were
any future Global threats let's say
something in the lines of a Gigan or a
space Gojira there would be no Titan
that would be fit enough to challenge
them and save humanity and if I would
only be for dominance or self-defense
against an alien attacker
so on the other Corner Kong is the last
member of the gigantic ape species
titanus gong his species originated in
the hollow Earth and with gong species
coexisting with humans in that place as
evident from ancient carvings and cave
paintings he serves at the guardian of
skeleton and Ergo The Garden of the
eeries and also maintaining a natural
order and also saving Wildlife Monarch
classifies him as a protector along with
Godzilla Mothra and Behemoth and
Methuselah while territorial Kong shows
altruistic Behavior rescuing animals and
saving humans from danger he is not
normally aggressive towards humans and
only attacks when provoked in gxk he
forms a deep bone with the characters he
is in contact with especially Jia and
shows that he has the IQ comparable to
us along with empathy and language
so there are four implications and
consequences if Kong was to die in gxk
firstly the skullcrawler's population
might expand again and if they go
unchecked they will eventually devour
surface life forms until there is
nothing left secondly there would be a
loss of a human Titan link knowledge on
the evolution as well as losing a
protected Titan would deal a huge blow
not only to Monarch but Humanity as a
whole thirdly Hollow Earth will be of
limits why because that place isn't
meant for us to venture in there and be
a part of isn't really what we are meant
to do humans there aren't at the top of
the food chain so without Kong who
serves as a protector of the Explorers
there every other creature would start
picking off people one by one as prey
items and then lastly without Kong there
is no deterrence to a rope Godzilla or a
last line of defense against other
hostile tyrants if this was to ever
happen then the most of us has to come
up with Jaegers or gigantic metal robots
to fight off impending threats
so that's it I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit that like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos here on
this channel take care fam